le premier ministre et les ministres
heureux de vous retrouver pour ce
premier conseil des ministres ce nouveau
gouvernement dans une période aurons
l'occasion d'y revenir
marqué par
l'exceptionnelle d'exceptionnel d'abord
la guerre revenu sur le sol européen et
qui finalement frappé d'abord l'ukraine
mais nous y reviendrons tout à l'heure
rapidement dans la partie communication
est
au coeur de conséquences profondes pour
nos sociétés pour le projet européen
pour notre économie la ville nos
compatriotes période exceptionnelle sur
le plan aussi des transitions que nous
avons à vivre période exceptionnelle
compte tenu également de des situations
politiques iep et celle ci impose
gouvernement beaucoup de volontarisme
d'ambition parce que notre pays a besoin
de réformes de transformation dans les
politiques publiques que vous aurez
apporté durant les années qui viennent
il a besoin aussi l'esprit de
responsabilité pour bâtir des compromis
exigeant
dans ce contexte vous aurez d'abord à
tenir tenir dans ce contexte de guerre
qui changent en profondeur beaucoup de
choses et je pense que ça n'a pas été
suffisamment intégré dans le débat
public français
bâtir l'indépendance du pays et les
progrès pour nos compatriotes
et quel que soit là aussi les politiques
dont nous parlions ça suppose de savoir
investir j'y reviendrai transformer
bâtir mais
l'indépendance du pays et les progrès se
finisse que rarement sur des déficits
non financées en tout cas non soutenable
et
l'indépendance réelle du pays ne se fait
pas sans transformation profonde
et beaucoup d'exigence et puis nous
aurons un à construire des transitions
dans la durée et qu'il s'agisse
évidemment du défi écologique qu'il
s'agisse des grandes transitions
démographiques
on n'en citer que deux elle impose de
profondément transformé l'action
collective qui est la nôtre de repenser
avec les élus locaux avec l'ensemble de
nos administrations avec aussi les
partenaires que sont les entreprises les
associations les citoyens en profondeur
nombre de nos politiques publiques
la première ministre m'a rendu compte
vendredi du résultat des consultations
conduites la semaine dernière
il convient de prendre acte de l'absence
de volonté des parties gouvernement de
participer à un accord de gouvernement
ou toute forme de coalition
[Musique]